a couple of weeks ago on March 25th a
researcher from the University of
Massachusetts conducted an interesting
survey he reached out to 20 eminent
epidemiologists and public health
experts and he asked a simple question
he asked how many Americans will die
from this outbreak of the corona virus
the average estimate he got back was 245
thousand people as it happens that
number matched almost exactly the
projection from the Institute for Health
metrics and evaluation at the University
of Washington the group has created the
most influential model of the pandemic
as recently as yesterday you heard some
authorities cite those numbers
effectively in public hundreds of
thousands will die well that estimate
has changed dramatically
this morning the IHM II issued brand new
numbers his researchers now project
60,000 deaths in this country by August
4th that's one quarter of the original
projection numbers for individual states
have changed as well in Virginia for
example which is currently suffering
under a lock down until June the model
now predicts a total of 891 deaths
statewide just a week ago the eye hme
projected three thousand seventy three
deaths in Virginia that's more than
three times what they're now saying at
this point we should not be surprised
that the model got it wrong the eye hmes
prediction of how many hospital beds
we'd need turned out to be completely
disconnected from reality and that
matters quite a bit it turns out because
those numbers were the main
justification for this lockdown remember
our efforts to flatten the curve they
weren't crazy was a good reason for
doing that we didn't want our health
care system to collapse under a flood of
new coronavirus patients and so far it
has not collapsed but not because we
prepared effectively we didn't really
there were just far fewer people who
needed inpatient medical treatment than
we thought there would be
for example the model predicted that on
April 4th New York would need 65,000
Hospital that's the actual number was
16,000 now you're hearing people now say
that the spread between the prediction
and the reality must be due to social
distancing but that is not true social
distancing measures were factored into
the model from the beginning the
prediction turned out to be four times
larger than what actually happened
social distancing didn't do that
something else skewed the numbers we
don't
what it is we should find out at the
same time though the IH ME has been far
more accurate on death totals in some
cases they've been significantly
overstated but not by 400% pretty close
in a lot of cases today as we've told
you the IH am e announced that about
60,000 Americans will die by the time
the virus presumably recedes in the
summer heat that's an awful lot of
people but it's far from the largest
death toll we will see this year for
perspective we're going to read you now
a series of numbers now some people may
be offended to hear this but there's no
reason to be accurate statistics are not
offensive
they reflect reality and reality should
always be the baseline from which we
make important decisions even if we
ourselves have made other predictions in
the past even if we're embarrassed to
admit what we now know we should do it
anyway because ego doesn't matter at a
time like this
the truth matters so here are a few
numbers as we said an estimated 60,000
Americans will die from the corona virus
according to the CDC in 2018 61 thousand
Americans died of the annual flu that
same year more than 67 thousand died
from drug overdoses nearly 50 thousand
died from suicide about 88 thousand
Americans died from alcohol abuse 83
thousand died from diabetes more than
six hundred and six thousand died from
cancer could go on but for now let's
look at two of those numbers overdoses
and suicides both by the way
disproportionately kill young people
let's say the IHI me death projections
are too low for the sake of argument and
this would be the first time that's
happened but again just for the sake of
this exercise let's assume the real
number is twice as big it's a hundred
and twenty thousand that's how many
Americans will die in this outbreak if
that's true that would still be around
as many people as died from overdoses
and suicides both of which are leaders
essentially ignore deaths like those are
not considered a government problem yet
in the last several weeks don't protect
ourselves from the wuhan coronavirus
which is dangerous and scary we have
thrown an estimated 17 million people
out of work
we have spent more than two trillion
dollars in borrowed money and that's
just the response so far now we're not
going to tell you that what our leaders
done in the last month is
disproportionate you can decide that for
yourself but it's definitely something
to think about going forward because
again reality matters even if it
embarrasses us to admit it many of our
politicians though don't seem to be
thinking about it in the face of
improving numbers in fact New Jersey
Governor Phil Murphy announced that his
state would quote if anything tighten as
opposed to loosen lockdown restrictions
statements like that make you wonder
what's really going on here is public
health really the only consideration for
these people maybe not here Zeke Emanuel
who's not only an academic but also a
longtime political hack explaining on
MSNBC this morning that America must
remain in its current state for a year
and a half now keep in mind at almost
the very moment that Zeke Emanuel said
this the IHM II was revising its total
death rate down to 260 thousand I do
think we're gonna turn to what we think
of as normal the sort of pre kovat 19
situation only with the vaccine or some
very effective preventative that
everyone can take that is 18 months away
and we need to keep very very clear
about that we're not getting that around
the corner you want to give everyone in
this country the benefit of the doubt in
the middle of a crisis but honestly you
have to wonder what motivates people to
say things like what you just heard if
you were sincerely trying to help the
country you would be focused on
effective medical treatments for this
disease
a drug that saved even half of patients
heading toward death would change the
landscape immediately and forever in a
situation like this science is our hope
so you think our media would be
following every medical advance at least
as closely as we follow the Final Four
but no they're doing just the opposite
they're ignoring promising treatments in
favor of promoting ever more oppressive
social controls why are they doing that
in the case of the drug
hydroxychloroquine witch doctors are
giving right now to thousands of
coronavirus patients doctors who have
reporters rather who have no grounding
in science are telling us that it's
unproven and risky apparently in
contrast to everything
else we're doing without she's seen
those studies are not scientific and
chloroquine the drug used to treat
malaria and lupus also carries
cardiovascular risks but the president
continues to endorse the drug President
Trump is asked what do you have to lose
medical experts say your life what do
you have to lose well potentially you
lose your life experts say there isn't
enough clinical data to show it's
effective for coronavirus and it is some
serious side effects we continue today
to push hydroxychloroquine in a way that
is baffling to medical professionals
Gene Robinson you write in The
Washington Post the one word that proves
why President Trump should not be
President what is it
hydroxychloroquine these people have no
idea what they're talking about and they
don't care to learn you know exactly
what they're doing they're launching
partisan political attacks and
pretending it's medical advice that is
always wrong but right now in the middle
of a pandemic that is reckless and
immoral remember their names